here's a columnist for Newsweek and the
author of proof of collusion oh good and
the forthcoming book proof of conspiracy
Seth Abramson's thank you for being here
I hope they will get to the proof of
collusion soon but before we do that I
want to just talk about your technique
because I think it's very exciting when
there's a new literary event and I would
say what you do is that I mean you're
what are the word you is accurate
ologist or accurate ology you're sure
it's real journalists I can't get that
but I get close and what you really do
is is put out a long long Twitter feed
I've read it and it's interesting
because it's like watching someone write
a book in real time you don't mind if
people see that you make mistakes you
erase stuff you amend stuff you edit
stuff so is this like the new version of
what we went through and maybe the 70s
when there was the new journalism when
they were mixing fact and fiction you
think this is as big a change well I
think it's definitely new we're in the
digital age now and what we find is not
that there isn't enough quality
journalism but that there's actually so
much of it that a lot of it falls
through the cracks it gets published
read once and then forgotten so what a
curatorial journalist does is they look
back decades across media that's being
published across different continents
and they see stories that are lost and
how they connect with one another and
how they might be important now but
weren't realized as important as that do
you connect the dots
exactly you're the guy at the evidence
wall essentially yep with the red tape
you know I I did a sketch of that once
but mine was yeah there it is we if we
put there's this
yeah there's Pat Donny in the middle and
but you do it for real and it's
interesting you you've said that Donald
Trump is the live embodiment of the
Internet what do you mean by that well
he is I mean he's ubiquitous he's in our
lives every second of every day he wants
to be in our lives every second of every
day and he's bad for us and he fatigues
us just like the Internet does
[Music]
you also have cities the first meta
modern criminal scandal this is the
first meta modern criminal scandal now
how what does that mean well it means
that everything Donald Trump does that
is illicit and in another period of time
would have been done behind closed doors
or secretly on an audiotape that we
don't have access to he does right in
public Russia if you're listening or any
of his other statements suggesting that
he's a wels colluding in plain sight I'm
glad you said that I've said that myself
for a long time so we did something
tonight
to illustrate this now the comparison of
course is always to Nixon but Nixon
tried everything he could to keep it
secret as you say Trump does the exact
opposite he does it in plain sight I
think this is the the genius to his
getting away with everything I don't
think he knows he's doing it I think
it's cuz he's a narcissist but this is
the effect of it so what we did was we
took some of the things that Trump has
said again in broad daylight we put them
on a tape just like he did with the
Nixon tapes now imagine if you were
hearing this for the first time in this
way where we just got this imagine that
Donald Trump was surreptitiously taped
and you heard it this way
now if if people had heard that wouldn't
we say that's The Smoking Gun
it's possible but you know the other
thing bill is that there are things that
he does behind closed doors right
negotiating for two years while he was
running for president a multi-billion
dollar real estate deal with the Kremlin
and with Russians right but when that
comes out and when we find out about it
he then does 10 12 20 things that seem
just as bad within the next 24 to 48
hours right and as a result we lose
sight of how important even the hidden
thing that becomes public is but there
was a guy who was trying to put these
dots together for two years Robert
Muller why did he punt on this why did
he not you know call I mean answer the
call of history when it was so plainly
his job to do that I mean I thought I
thought this guy I guess we all did was
was gonna be the one to say here because
as I've said before just what we know
and this is what you do you put down
just what we know what is in his mind do
you think well I think a lot of people
are saying that he punted and I don't
think that that's accurate right on
obstruction
he knew that he couldn't indict the
president you can't indict a sitting
president under DOJ regulations and
therefore he wanted to pass that case
through to Congress had he made a
judgment on obstruction he might have
lost gravitas he might have had 50% of
the country who are more conservative
considering him to be a boogeyman
because now he's put his finger on the
scale he maintained his gravitas by
saying here's all the evidence it had to
go to Congress anyway so here it is on
the question of collusion I think we
have to understand that the law
investigation hasn't really ended it has
simply transformed into now 20 pending
federal and state investigations in
jurisdictions all around the country
where the evidence that Muller collected
on the question of collusion bribery
aiding and abetting money laundering
illegal solicitation of campaign
donations is now being looked at by
federal prosecutors from California all
the way to New York City and Virginia
and what will be the upshot of that
I think Trump leaving office I don't see
that from well I'd say that's right we
sometimes say you know how could there
be no finding of conspiracy by Robert
Malley right or that he could not
establish beyond reasonable doubt that
there was conspiracy
the interesting thing bill is that no
one was really accusing Donald Trump of
having a before the fact signed
agreement with the internet research
agency that was doing all the propaganda
or the GRU Russian military intelligence
that was doing the hacking that's not
how conspiracies work if you don't say
right exactly Cohen said that he said
Trump never gives you an order he says
what he thinks is reality which isn't at
the time but you take that as his
underling that you would he would like
you to carry out something that would
make that happen right and as
importantly that's not how bribery works
which is fundamentally what we're going
to be looking at and what a lot of these
are investigations are looking at
whether Donald Trump's sold America's
foreign policy in exchange for personal
right that's still being looked at by
some of these jurisdictions as well as
aiding and abetting which is when you
know someone's committing a crime and
then you offer them an inducement to
continue this bar investigation now is
looking into he wants to look into the
origins of the investigation well I
think in I read in your a piece that
there were five American allies who
warned us about contacts that they had
picked up their intelligence services
right picked up between the Russians
Russian agents and Trump operatives
right this is July of 2016 and this is
actually how the counterintelligence
investigation of the Trump campaign or
individuals in that campaign started is
our allies our friends were worried
about our national security so five of
their Intel agencies told us hey there
are meetings happening in Europe between
Trump advisers and Russians that are
incredibly concerning and that's what
got everything started it wasn't the
steel dossier it wasn't it will that be
in the report well we don't know what's
going to be in the mall or how could it
not be if that's what happened you know
that happened yes no there's no question
that that happened the question is how
much of mother's report is going to
focus on why the investigation started
when as I think many people believe
that's really immaterial to the findings
of the investigation and the steel tape
that steel dossier and the P tape let's
be honest that's the
yeah I've heard you who say that you
think that's such a real thing that the
Donald Trump paid two hookers to pee on
each other I don't believe that well I
believe they did it I don't believe he
paid what I know and what we all know is
that in January of 2017 the BBC
contacted the CIA and asked the question
any good investigative journalists would
ask which is do these tapes exist and we
know because the BBC published this in
January 2017 that the CIA got back to
the BBC and said there are multiple
tapes from multiple locations and they
are of a sexual nature and they involve
Donald Trump what happened after that is
British media then followed up on that
BBC report the independent The Telegraph
the garden of BBC and they found lots of
evidence that there were witnesses who
saw women who were going to be signed in
to go up to his room and they were
arguing about whether they would have to
put their names down that was all
reported in British media I couldn't
tell you why it's not reported in
America but that's why I'm a curatorial
journalist so I can find that
information let people know it's there
even if they're not reading it here
domestically so
[Music]
maybe you're kind of picking up where a
julian assange was before he went bad
because we used to like him you know he
used to really be doing a good service
and then something happened I guess his
hatred for Hillary Clinton maybe is what
turned him basically into someone who
was a Russian aide really and somebody
who helped Trump get elected now he just
got out of the embassy but it's not
gonna be good for him what why didn't
mother get to him I mean it seems like
he knows a lot that whole thing with
Roger stone and WikiLeaks why couldn't
Muller have gone after him well Julian
Assange his case is in the Eastern
District of Virginia and right now one
of the 20 pending federal and state
investigations into Trump his family his
aides his associates his allies is in
the Eastern District of Virginia and so
prosecutors once they get him stateside
will be in a position to ask him
questions that all of us want answers to
for instance did he have contact with
Trump advisers Ted Malek Paul Manafort
Donald Trump jr. Randi credito Jerome
Corsi all these people who we've seen
reports in the past and again these are
reports that sort of disappeared and I
tried to bring them back through threads
on so try to say look this is happening
all these people allegedly had contact
with Julian Assange that could be a
focal point for collusion so hopefully
someone's gonna ask that question did
you talk to these guys please keep doing
it we need you on that wall the evidence
for coffee whatever it's a
all right thank you sir
you